I just typed in here's the top 100
overused business cliches yet man here's
thinking outside the box
Oh win-win situation of best practice
synergy oh no
synergy here's here's one that that I
don't think I ever heard anyone say
because even nah I can imagine some of
the people where we used to work would
say it yeah paradigm shift yes oh yes
low-hanging fruit push the envelope mmm
value-added proposition good God core
competency a leading provider of that's
what we used to talk about a leading
provider of telecom or data services
man you know that with the previous one
it's only one word away from value-added
segments right it's time for our
value-added proposition
[Laughter]
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to episode
119 today we're gonna talk about
decoration decorations we're sitting in
our new studio right now heavily
decorated with sound panels yeah it's
funny because we are going to do a video
version of this podcast eventually once
we get enough patreon supporters to get
all the the video equipment but it's one
of the things that we've been thinking
about we've been talking to Matt the
director the director of our documentary
we'll be talking to podcast Sean is here
with us today and trying to figure out
like well what's I mean obviously this
office has the appropriate appropriate
aesthetic for us right now mm-hmm
but how do you and right now we're just
wedding we're supposed to have this
light installed yesterday I'm pointing
up with the ceiling for those of you
listening to this and it just didn't
work because we need some other brackets
and I need to hire an electrician and
all kinds of crazy stuff to make what
happen but point being is I think the
lighting will be the last thing that
really adds the last aesthetic but it's
it's aggressively simple in here but
it's you know these these matte gray
walls with black sound panels woman yeah
and you don't really don't want to muck
it up I look at some sets now of
different podcasts or different TV shows
and I'm wondering like how do they just
have a random bookshelf there in fact
that was an idea Matt had he sent to me
as I maybe there should be a bookshelf
and so I sent him like pictures of
ridiculous bookshelves like people have
randomly people put like a basketball or
a football on their bookshelf I'm like
wait a minute who puts a basketball on a
bookshelf the metaphor Josh for
dribbling your dreams put that in the
show
dribble your dreams Ryan make sure if
that's a Ryan Nick
not the minimalists no man I love our
studio I mean the I guess you could say
that each sound panel is like its own
work of art and you know what in some
like in some modern Museum dude like
this and I have actually seen that
before where it's like just some black
or white panels in a row and that's it
yeah there was the did you see the guys
either at LACMA I was at LACMA this past
weekend it was it was great but I think
it made Ben LACMA or it could have been
the MoMA or the San Francisco MoMA there
was a guy who went into one of the the
empty rooms where there they were
switching out the the current display or
whatever was supposed to be on display
in that room so there was nothing in
that room and he walked in there and he
just took his eyeglasses off set it in
the middle of the floor and it just
started standing around it looking down
and like and like rubbing his chin and
he'd started taking photos and this
crowd of people started congregating
around him yeah so that they could they
too could look at this artwork that was
on the floor and so the and I think
we'll actually be talking about this
today because I think art is part of
decorating a house and what do we
determine what is art what isn't art and
and sort of art may be in the eye of the
beholder but I think you're right right
you look at some of these sound panels
and and they are art to a certain extent
when you go to museums part of the art
there is the sound scaping the sound
design of a place Max and I were eatin a
breakfast at a local restaurant here in
LA and this past weekend and we I
commented to her like the sound design
in this place is great because it was a
big open space but it sounded similar to
this so you could tell I mean they
probably spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars just on the sound of this place
and and having the appropriate acoustics
in there because it sounded like you
were in a sound booth even though it was
wide open and so I think that's part of
art as well as what does the place sound
like and when you go to a museum or you
go to a home it has a particular sound
to it and they may try to affect a
particular kind of echo as a podcast to
listen to called 99% invisible that they
talk about sometimes they talk about
sound design
whether you're in a Cathedral you want
you want a cathedral sound like a
Cathedral you don't want a cathedral to
sound like a mic booth right as that
would be really weird
we were on tour last year we we went to
Grand Rapids and there was this new
beautiful theater that had just opened
up you remember this and oh yeah I
remember walking in there and I was like
oh like I was talking to you and there
was there was very little reverb like
they had designed it really well
and I was talking to some of the folks
who worked there and they were like man
I just tell him like the sound is really
great but now I'm actually kind of
worried because you want a little bit of
reverb you want the laughter if someone
if you tell a joke you want that to
reverberate it makes other people laugh
and they feel like they're in that
environment and they were saying that
some musicians especially like acoustic
kind of musicians love this space
because acoustically it was gorgeous but
when they got like heavy rock bands in
there that it sometimes that sucks the
energy out of the room right and so part
of decoration we think when we say
decorations we think of the visual side
of things and I think that's what we'll
be talking about most today but but
there are other senses that we that we
try to fulfill you know that the who was
it was a Aristotle or yeah I think was
Aristotle who said there were five
senses right the touch and and taste and
smell and sight visual yeah yeah yeah
but but physicists now believe that
there are something like between 22 and
32 different senses right like the sense
of balance and and and like literally
balance like to keep me from not falling
out of this chair which would be
possible if all of a sudden the room
started spinning in my head right I
could fall out of the chair but but that
that is a sense of but balance isn't
just a literal balance but like when you
come into a room like this like it feels
balanced because I'm looking at all the
the sound panels here right and it's
evenly spaced and you get a sense of
symmetry or maybe there's an intentional
sense of asymmetry and we talk about
decorating I think we're 99% focused on
the visual but what about the other the
other side of things how do
how does the decorations how do they
make you feel that's the kinesthetic
feeling how does it sound when you walk
into a home or a museum or into a studio
space or what's what's the acoustic or
the sound design and and then how does
it make you feel sort of internally like
when I walk into space so I feel calm
do I feel frenetic do I feel anxious do
I feel soothed do I feel meditative
there I can think of when you go to a
few airports now the I think la there's
or the San Francisco there's a yoga room
yeah not LA although I think maybe in
one of the the terminals in LA there is
a meditation room or yoga room that does
not surprise me at all the airport that
I know of that it's had a meditation
room for the longest time and I bet
you've never been in it I've never been
in it I've been there for a bunch the
Dayton International Airport that's
awesome I had no idea there's a
meditation room it just kind of looks
like a prayer room but it's it's really
small and it's not past the gate that
the gate so it's a weird place to have
it but if you just want to go meditate
that was the first place I've ever seen
that had just the meditations also man
yeah and so so there are we talked about
the the way a space makes us feel we set
up a space so that we ideally we should
set up a space that we get a particular
feeling I have never been like a
believer well not even a believer as
much as I just don't know anything about
function why the lake having these
conversations the way I felt after the
packing party the way I felt like the
first time I sat on my couch and like
there wasn't all these just all this
clutter distracting me from from
focusing like absolutely had a
completely different internal feeling I
need to read more here have you ever
read anything on function way like do
you just a little bit I had someone send
us a book once about it and she had just
written about it and I think you have to
be ready ready for that like in fact
right now could be a really good time
for me because we just moved into a new
apartment a few months ago a couple
months ago and have been trying to very
slowly populate it with the right decor
for lack of a better term right because
aesthetics are important to me but they
shouldn't be the the most important
thing you don't you don't wanna build a
facade around a crumbling house it's
Fung Shui
Fung Shui that fun times fast this
function way there's like a like a
spiritual element to it is that correct
there can be the same way there can be
with respect to meditation oh ok so
meditation so it's something that's not
like it's not built around a spiritual
belief well meditation originally was
right and so you know when you think of
either Hindu or Buddhist meditation you
know it is built around a set of
spiritual or religious beliefs however
you can tweeze it out of that context
just like you can with Fung Shui there's
not a religious connotation with Fung
Shui that I'm aware of but but there is
a sort of spiritual alignment side of
things good so if anyone has any
resources for us if you have a good
recommendation for a website or a book
to read about Fung Shui just hit us up
on on Twitter at the minimalists we have
it here about that and in fact I know
last week we mentioned that we might be
talking a little bit this week about how
the minimalists are using social media
in 2018
I think were gonna save that for next
week I think it'd probably be most
appropriate instead of trying to cram
that into a decoration episode do a
separate episode just about social media
and so if you've got questions about
that we'll reach out to you on social
media but in the meantime if you want to
check out an essay Shawn's actually
editing it today but by the time this
podcast episode comes out it will be up
there it's called how the minimalists
are using social media in 2018 so just a
brief overview with that Ryan and I took
the month of January 2018 off of social
media would deleted all of our tweets
and Instagram posts and went silent on
Pinterest and and Facebook and and just
sort of step back and learn some lessons
unlearn some bad habits I think and I
think we we just will spend maybe a
whole episode a shorter episode talking
about that maybe answering some
questions about social media as well
that way we don't have to try to cram
that into into this episode so Ryan you
were talking about decorating style and
function and then of course sort of the
accidental Fung Shui of doing the
packing party and then in fact the the
chapter in our book everything the
remains that covers the the packing
party or the aftermath of the pack
party so to speak it's called the sound
of minimalism and and I really think
that's that's kind of what it was is
like you waking up and realizing like
okay I have to unpack my couch because
you literally packed up everything as if
you were moving and it's been yeah the
next three weeks unpacking so for day
one you're like okay I need my couch I'm
gonna unpack that take the sheet off of
it and then you you sit down you're like
oh like all of this this excess that I
didn't question before now I'm
questioning it because like it's it's
not there and it literally sounds
different in the home but in addition to
the sounding different it feels
different to you you don't have all of
this sort of these items on your
periphery you don't have the clutter in
front of you and what kind of feelings
do you feel like that you you were
experiencing at first when when you had
be when you began letting go yeah as I
said earlier um it was it was less
distracting that was like the biggest
that was the biggest thing I noticed
you're not a very anxious person for me
no no no I know I know there's a
reduction in anxiety oh yeah no for me
it's late well I guess maybe it was
anxiety I'm not an anxious person person
I would not have described the feeling
of less distraction as being less
anxious but I mean I certainly could
feel that way but it was just easier to
concentrate it was easier to you know if
I'm because I sat down on my couch put
my laptop on the coffee table right and
I'm sitting there working on my laptop
listen home Ryan's mimicking yes and I
had not unpacked my TV at that point so
just sitting there with my laptop and
then the coffee table I could see across
like it was just not having the the
other screen in front of the the screen
I was looking at yeah was like this
automatic sense of just being able to
concentrate more even if the TV was off
it's really weird man
um other feelings man I don't know um I
would love to sit here and be like oh
man
so clear clarity man I guess in a way it
was clarity just in the sense of I was
realizing that my mind was filled with a
lot of just a lot of clutter that was in
direct relation to the physical clutter
I had yeah it spawns this and in and not
just spawns but but fuels this internal
clutter right yeah I mean you know like
after I got rid of you know 80% of my
stuff like I just remember you know not
having to think about that storage
closet that I had that I and there was
always this like one day I'm gonna go
through that storage closet and I'm
gonna like get rid of this stuff I don't
need to keep the stuff I want so the
packing party forced me to confront all
that stuff yeah and I guess I just
didn't realize how having that storage
closet cleared out like taking the
action and actually doing it how great
of a feeling that was but then also not
having that weighing on my mind at all
it's not like like dude I never it's not
like I got home every single day from
working I was like cleaning out that
storage closet one day got it like I
never thought of it like that it was
always something that I would just keep
procrastinating it was simmering way way
yeah yeah on the 17th back burner right
like it like a total like not even
didn't even realize it was on my radar
but once it was gone I was like oh wow
like it feels good to not have that to
to procrastinate anyway yeah you feel a
weight lifted in a way and I when I when
I think about you clearing out that
house and and and reducing for me what
what it would be anxiety for you it's
just it's it's clearing that internal
clutter and and I don't think we often
associate the two we we imagine that
like we have this robust interior life
and that was completely separate somehow
from our exterior life but of course we
know that that isn't true it can be
separate to certain extent you can have
the most perfect house and all the
perfect decorations and and have
everything neatly organized in an
ordinal alphabetized system and still be
miserable inside
and the opposite is also true you can
live amongst a whole bunch of trash heap
of clutter and have some sort of sort of
internal peace but it's harder to do
that and so there tends to be a
congruence with what's going on outside
with the the decor of our lives the
aesthetics of our lives I think back to
I heard some Rob Bell say something
about he was talking about the
importance of aesthetics like we often
discount aesthetics because we
especially for someone like me or you we
we try to avoid you know mass
consumption or consumerism and part of
that is like well look at the shiny
thing I bought that's not necessarily
aesthetics though yeah these are
attracted to flowers because they're
beautiful that's why they're beautiful
it's to attract the bees right and and I
think it the same can be true with our
homes we can we can make our home
beautiful without all the excess stuff
and attractive bees I see exactly we're
going with this right I mean ultimately
at the end of the day at the end of the
day want to be a beekeeper all right
let's get into these voicemails Ryan and
I are laughing right now because we just
we accidentally recorded a patreon bonus
episode Sean we gotta either put that at
the beginning of this if it works out
somehow or just make it a separate five
minute patreon bonus episode we were
reading a list of all the corporate
jargon that we had to go through back in
our corporate days the list of the
hundred most overused vapid trite
corporate isms is the way I would call
identify them and at the end of the day
was on the list which is something I
still have not been able to stop using
Ryan has shed ninety nine of the top 100
that's right I still use that one he's
clinging at the end of the day is my um
at the end of the day you're right all
right you know we do have some questions
we should probably we should probably
dive into those so I wrote this thing
down actually it's probably something
that's better it's more appropriate for
one of these these questions here Chloe
from Texas has a question
as an artist and as a musician but also
as a minimalist I try to build an
environment that's conducive to
creativity we're about being cluttered
or overwhelming however there are
certain beautiful objects I suppose most
obviously pieces of art that there's no
functional purpose but that if you'll
make up the environment that item looks
comfortable and so in functional
minimalism do you believe there's a
space for aestheticism or am i putting
too much stock too much value into these
objects by keeping him around under the
notion that they are necessary for me to
create she talked about the the
functional purpose like like having
beautiful objects without a functional
purpose and I think she worded that
really well because what I would say is
functional purpose isn't always the only
purpose when you and I talk about adding
value we talk about serving a purpose a
functional purpose being useful in some
way or bringing you joy I think that's a
different type of purpose it's not a
direct function it's like well I own a
can opener because I want to open cans
it's a little bit different it's you
might might be owning a piece of art
that goes on the wall and for me art is
different she talked about the beautiful
objects and and I'd like to expand the
definition of our because when we hear
the term art we think of like a painting
that's on the wall that's the first
thing that comes to my mind is like you
see the Picasso at the brood Museum or
wherever broad museum and or you you see
you see maybe a sculpture that is is art
but I think of everyday objects as art
as well I don't know how you feel about
that but for me I don't own a whole lot
of things in fact we were doing a mold
test in my house in my new apartment
yesterday because I'd mentioned last
week that I'd been sick for like six
over the last eight weeks and hopefully
it's just flu season and it was just
total coincidence but I wanted to rule
it out so I brought this sky over to do
this really comprehensive mold test and
he walks in he's like where's all your
stuff
and the funny thing is we actually we're
still waiting on a couch to show up so
we have this like really cheap loner
couch they gave us it looks like
something from a porn set and he walks
he's like where's all your stuff and I'm
like I'm like are you the handyman sit
over here I'll tell you on the couch
Thanks can you grab him some lemonade so
I'm thinking about well he walked in and
he's like where's our stuff and I'm like
oh a minimalist because I smell a
documentary about that that's very good
he goes wait a minute you look familiar
[Music]
anyway we we were talking about like the
the we got to just talking about the the
beauty of certain items like I have like
a little I guess you called a Media
Console or credenza or something and to
me that is a piece of art I don't hang a
lot of stuff on my walls I think we have
three photographs in the house and it's
not to say that I won't ever put
anything on the wall or whatever I see
but but my rule and I mentioned this on
last week's collections episode my rule
is I don't need anything on the walls to
be complete and thus if I decide to add
something it's because it will serve
some sort of purpose now may not be as
Chloe asked here it may not be a
functional purpose I can't take the
picture off the wall and use it as a can
opener
although patent pending we both on the
panel have to go back to the replay on
that to see you so I think that I think
that no it doesn't have to be functional
in fact it's great when it can be I
owned a few chairs at least one chair
from from Herman Miller and it's a piece
of art I mean it looks to me it looks
like a sculpture it's also pretty
comfortable I enjoy looking at it and so
it's this aesthetic beauty and I don't
have to hang it on the wall although you
could it's so beautiful and and that is
that is a piece of art that is in my
home and some people may or may not call
it our
and the the thing that she asked about
Ryan was she used the word aesthetic ISM
and at first it sounded like she said
asceticism it's not what we're we're
promoting no I didn't but they are sort
of the the exact opposite in a way right
because aesthetics are like the natural
beauty of the space and and a person who
is an ascetic is a person who
intentionally deprives themselves sort
of of the aesthetics and of everything
else beyond the the aesthetics and I
actually prefer the aesthetic side of
things that said I have to be really
careful we've we've been really slow
about populating our space with the
appropriate items and when I say
appropriate I mean appropriate for me
and for Backson and for Ella you know we
got Ella a new bed and a little
nightstand and there's a rocking chair
in her room because Bex likes to get
rocker to sleep actually it's BEC
doesn't like it Ella likes to be rocked
to sleep every night and and so there
are things she has a dresser there that
looks relatively good the dressers from
Ikea and IKEA does a decent job of
creating aesthetically pleasing items
that are a freaking nightmare to put
together have you seen that article
about a couple it's I think there's a
man let's see if we can find this real
quick Ryan there I saw either a blog or
an article about couples having fights
in IKEA fights and I like that's what
the majority of couples fights happen I
know but I do remember you and Kerry
moving into your huge house and you
bought a bunch of IKEA furniture and you
and I were putting it together and it
took us so long to just do like a couple
things we were like this is stupid we're
gonna we're gonna hire a handyman to do
this so you so Kerry called hired a
handyman who came out put together like
half of a bed and then literally just
walked out and quit yeah left you guys
so fresh
[Music]
yes quit yeah this is uh business I hope
not I hope he suffered no it was really
it was miserable for me because there
was half a bed put together my bedroom
and in the howl was a 25 or 24 something
like that and and I'm like okay it's
9:00 p.m. I just got off working a
14-hour day and now I have to try to
spend the next four hours putting this
bed together yeah yeah so I'll buy some
stuff from Ikea occasion the fact
whenever I go into an Ikea now it's like
Sean and I were there the other day
we're buying this table this is we have
a temporary table and because we're
waiting like three or four months to get
our our studio table and we were buying
this table did I tell a different story
on the panel if I told on the podcast or
not one of the live event so I was at
IKEA buying the dresser for Ella that's
in her room right now yeah and we
figured out just the right one had just
the right pop of color and it's it's a
great dresser for her it has a little
bookshelf on it as well
eventually once we're all settled in
hopefully we'll do like a health store
of each of our houses like we did back
in Montana and anyway I was buying this
and this woman comes up to me in line
and she's like oh yeah I know I told you
the story I don't know if I sold on the
park it was okay so so I she walks up to
me and she's like hey I recognize you
I'm Way okay hi how you doing I'm a
hugger my name's Josh and she she's like
no but I recognize you uh-huh
and she goes what are you doing here I'm
like I'm buying some stuff what do you
mean what am I doing here she goes
didn't you ask her weren't you like what
and so she goes you know I've really
been trying to simplify my life this
last year after seeing your documentary
I said then what are you doing here
and I pointed back to my cart and I said
this is everything I own and I don't
even own it yet and no and I think
that's the thing people get this
misconception like I like I want to live
like an ascetic no I want to live
like a person who brings things into
their life deliberately and that
includes having some sort of aesthetic
joy now for me my home tends to be more
stark than most people's and that's
because Becks and I and Ella are all
sort of on the same page even Ella I
know that when she goes to her her
biological father's house it is not the
same sort of aesthetics that we
appreciate and I know that she feels
she's expressed to us that she feels
calmer when she is with us and in fact
she's used similar terminology like it
feels nice here or that's or I love it
here you know and and and that's just
because she yeah she she's sort of over
stimulated and when in terms of sense
sensory things and so when there's just
too much there she feels the clutter but
I think we all feel it to a certain
extent it's like if someone were to
start yeah if you walked into a hoarders
house and had to live there all of a
sudden you'd be like I have to do
something about this right yeah so right
this uh this article from New York
magazine they're they're blog called the
cut so psychologists explain why IKEA is
a relationship deathtrap I don't know
what year this was but it says in honor
of Valentine's Day science of us is
spending this week talking about love
specifically what happens when it goes
wrong if you ever wondered about the
psychology of breakups we've got you
covered and then it goes on and says
it's been almost eight months now since
the last time I've cried in an Ikea I
feel that way Sean and I so we went to
go buy this desk but I also had to buy
one like container for backs and in
order to go find this one little tiny
it's like a for the kitchen pantry like
we had one that broke and so I wanted to
replace it but like you couldn't order
online because it was made out of glass
whatever so I'm like I'm not just gonna
go to Ikea to buy this one thing but
when we went to go buy this this table
that we're sitting at man Sean and I had
to walk through the whole store and it
was nervous making for me like a and it
was minute
we intentionally like waited to go on
like a Wednesday morning when no one
would be there kind of thing because it
could be crazy as hell they're on the
weekends especially up in Burbank and so
it goes on the problem I think was that
we had gotten too cocky everything had
been moving relatively smoothly my
boyfriend and I had picked out a
bookshelf without incident and a desk
and even found a coffee table narrow
enough for our teeny tiny living room it
was actually a TV stand but still we
were that couple that went to Ikea and
came out unscathed and then it was going
to our heads and then we got to the
kitchen carts and found ourselves and an
unfortunate gridlock kind of situation
situation one of them was too big one
was too small none were just right for
easily an hour we stayed by the kitchen
cards first debating whether to get one
at all and then eventually just standing
there and stony silence staring at our
options and then I started tearing up
out of both frustration and a strange
sense of loss I actually feel this way
every time I go to Ikea and by the way
people think this is a whole scene of me
reading about IKEA and everything that
remains remember in the documentary I'm
talking about you know going to Ikea and
buying all this stuff and people like
read that of not everyone I think small
minority people read that as a
indictment of Ikea it was an indictment
of me yeah my life was ending my mother
died my marriage ended what the hell am
i doing like figuring out what kind of
bath mats I need for my new apartment
and like is this a runner and what does
a throat to pillow I just where'd you I
thought they were called throat pillows
until I was 28 years old I don't know
anyway and and the funny thing is Beck's
and I are looking for a good throw
pillow right now just one though but I'm
not I'm not doing that as like the chaos
sort of tumbles down all around me and
that that was it was an indictment of my
priorities really yeah like where was
your head at exactly yeah I know Oh God
well I was gonna keep reading but good
oh no no I was gonna no you keep reading
all right well so at least we were in
good company efforts delightfully
Scandinavian product names and it's
meatballs
by the way I have to take a step back
Andrew Schultz of the brilliant idiot
it's one of my favorite podcasts he does
he's doing this weekly stand-up thing
where he releases a new joke every week
on his YouTube channel it's gonna he had
one about you know Scandinavian cuisine
and it was so good so I don't know if we
could find it but we might if we can
we'll put it in the show notes cool
the Swedish furniture the Swedish
furniture store might be best known for
its mysterious love busting powers and
there's a link here every relationships
greatest threat IKEA BuzzFeed has a
listicle of 19 ridiculous IKEA fights
that will make you want to be single
forever I am now I had to click on that
damn it Nancy I'm falling down the
rabbit hole number one oh my god this is
gonna be two hours if you're reading
IKEA article the frozen meatball mail a
number to the center log standoff oh man
there are like legitimate like fight
come on man well if only one of us can
be a DD man you know I'm gonna here's
what I'm gonna do I am going to deplane
from this IKEA built structure and we'll
just put a link to both of these in the
show notes why so many couples are are
fighting at IKEA from New York Magazine
and then the 19 ridiculous IKEA fights
that will make you want to be single
forever didn't BuzzFeed you know what I
found interesting about Khloe's question
so we get this a lot from artists where
they say oh I'm an artist and I've got
all this equipment that I've got to hold
on to and I need to create art like
that's that's totally the question I
thought we were gonna get yeah but she
wasn't asking about she wasn't asking
about the clutter she holds on to to
create art she was asking about what in
the stuff she holds on that inspires her
yes and dude like at the end of the day
you know having something I just said
under the day I put a nickel a podcast
is over
you should start your own podcast called
at the end the other day I would listen
to that oh my goodness man so so what
I'm getting at is is that Chloe Josh and
I yeah we we don't we don't we don't
pitch that people become ascetics what
Josh and I really want to help people do
is have things in their life that adds
value that serves a purpose or brings
them joy and we want them to have
everything else out of the way yes and
Chloe what it sounds like to me is
you've got some really cool things that
inspire you and maybe they don't serve a
a functional purpose but I would argue
that they serve a purpose for for your
being able to create I think the Mayans
I think they might not - I think the
things so we talked about this last week
the things that I liked aren't
necessarily the things that I like yeah
sometimes we hold on to those things and
so maybe what she could do is a
temporary packing party yet some of
those things that that she sees love
that idea you know she sees us you know
maybe this in fact she said oh do I give
too much stock to these things and that
I feel are necessary to create she feels
they're necessary to create here's the
key they're not necessary to create
maybe they maybe they do augment the
experience for you I can tell you if I
you look at my desk it faces a blank
wall mm-hmm and that is what's most
necessary for me and I've done that for
a long time in fact I remember when I
lived in my small apartment in Dayton
Ohio I had a desk pushed up against a
window and and for me looking out the
window was trouble so I would put any
time I went to go right I would shut the
curtain because I I don't want to be
influenced by the outside world when I'm
writing and so a blank wall was the most
ideal for me and before that it was a
small little desk pushed up against a
brick wall and and because I want my
creativity come to come from inside not
from the exterior however if those
things do actually augment your
experience great maybe do your own
little 21 day packing party with just
those elements that you find to be not
functional but they do serve a potential
purpose for you and that will that will
let you know whether or not they
actually do and if they do great hold on
to them if not pass them on somewhere
else maybe someone else can get some
value from yeah I think Chloe needs to
ask herself too like did she call and
ask us this question because it is it is
seriously like stressing her out like is
there is there anxiety that she feels
from having these possessions or does
she think that's you know if we came to
her house and saw these items like you
know we would judge her or her
minimalist friends would judge her for
it because if that's the case then I
would I would I would absolutely say
like don't ever get rid of something
because of how someone else is gonna
judge you like that's a that's a bad
that's a bad way to determine how you
live your life is on how other people
judge you and the same is true with with
bringing new things into your life and
we're gonna talk about that in a minute
with Julia or a next question but but
yeah you don't want to hold on to
something B or bring something new into
your life because someone is going to
judge you about that thing right it's
not for them it's for you right you also
don't want to let go of something
because you're like huh I wonder if this
will help my minimalist street cred all
right so our minimalist house cred yeah
so I think if I think honestly you know
if Chloe can look her self in the mirror
and answer that question honestly
that'll let her know what she needs to
do with with those items and and the
thing that I wrote down here is step
slowly to avoid going too far and so
maybe the packing party is a big too big
of a step well the thing I like about
doing a packing party is it doesn't
force you to get rid of everything we're
not saying hey why don't you just go
ahead donate all that stuff and then see
whether or not it added value to your
life because you get rid of and you're
like oh now I have to reacquire these
things because I actually I do miss them
that's silly but if you pack them up and
put them somewhere put them in the trunk
of your car or and it calls it if you
have the space or basement wherever and
you sits in a box or two and you unpack
it slowly so maybe that's that's a
that's something pithy you can put in
the show notes there Shawn step slowly
to avoid going too far
so maybe getting rid of those things
slowly and then of course for me the
opposite is true is since we moved into
this new apartment it's kind of driving
me crazy because there are some things
where I'm like all right we were this
couch three months ago and I'm still
waiting for it to show up and so I have
this pornstar couch and the me
time and and and and but I'm also
appreciating the fact that like anything
that we bring into our home I'm doing so
deliberately and I'm going to do so very
slowly it's a it's sort of an experiment
in in temporary deprivation in a way
right and and the other thing that I'll
just echo or append we were talking
about the objects right and she
mentioned the the beautiful objects
without function and I think that
beautiful objects are important we
talked about the the flower metaphor we
talked about the basketball in the
bookshelf metaphor and that was not a
metaphor Oh dribble your dreams I feel
like we if we did more than one shot if
we did more than one word titles for
pockets episodes this one would be
called dribble your dreams Joan why are
you letting me derail us like this man
so I've got this book that just came out
from Carl Oh of Knopf scarred I think
you read his my struggle book yeah one
of the six and he he just put this out
in the the way that it's described it's
so it's called a winter I will put a
link to this in the show notes as well
in winter we were joined Carl of CONOPS
guard as he waits for the birth of his
daughter and preppers preparation for
arrival he takes stock of the world
seeing it as if for the first time in
his sensitive style he writes about the
moon water messiness owls birthday is
just a name a handful of subjects he
fills these oh so familiar objects and
ideas with new meaning taking nothing
for granted or as given and so it's
what's really fascinating about this
they're really really short chapters and
he he is somehow able to write about the
most banal things not in a gorgeous way
like someone like David Foster Wallace
or Don DeLillo or Mary Karr would do but
but in a way that is just very
matter-of-fact but it's almost like it
puts you in a trance and you keep
reading so he has he what he's doing is
he's writing these little short letters
to his unborn daughter and he's talking
about different objects and ideas and so
one of the chapters in here is just
called chairs I'm gonna read a quick
excerpt from
because it's what he's doing basically
is appreciating an object the same way a
kid appreciates it I notice it with LnL
when we're walking around LA there's so
many freaking flowers just by houses it
takes us an hour to get 15 10 15 minute
walk to the store cuz she will literally
stop and smell every single flower and
then she'll go back and smell once she
smelled a minute ago to compare them and
I think Carl over here he he he does the
same thing with these sort of everyday
objects so I'm just gonna read a quick
excerpt from the chairs chapter and this
a chair is for sitting on it consists of
four legs upon which rests aboard and
from the end of this rises a backrest
all these elements can be executed in
various ways shaped differently and
using different materials but the basic
shape is fixed and unalterable if one of
the elements is missing such as the
backrest is no longer a chair but
something else in this case a stool the
chair is related to the bench and the
sofa which are also for sitting on yet
is still radically separate from them
for the chair is for one person and one
person only which is an essential aspect
of its character the chair isolates us
it is like a little island in the room
to which no one else has access as long
as someone else is in possession of it
the chair is a symbol of power the King
has his throne the chieftain has his
chair the minister has his seat in the
government but the chair is also
something everyone has at home and which
everyone infants as well as the very old
sits on every day and like everything
that the body uses regularly from stairs
to door handles water taps and coffee
cups to tables and remote controls soap
dispensers and clothes hangers the
particular chair with its particular
appearance is lost is lost sight of when
we enter a room with chairs in it we
know they are there without this
certainty usually reaching our
consciousness and becoming a clearly
formula
thought it is as it is as if we live in
a world of shadows and so I'm so glad my
36 year old self can appreciate writing
like that because my 25 year old stuff
would have been like the hell is Josh
reading me right now
but I think I think what he's trying to
point out here is there's beauty within
the boring there's beauty within the
banality of of a chair or a piece of art
and it's up to us to appreciate it the
thing that was described though I was
reading about the book and it talks
about he he fills these oh so familiar
objects and ideas with new meaning and
that's really what we do the the things
don't have an intrinsic meaning in our
home in our life other than the meaning
we give it and in this case he's filling
it with meaning yes I like chairs I like
the way that they look I have a weird
fascination with chairs personally but
the way he described it there and very
simple terms is like oh yeah you know it
there is a particular meaning that we
give to these objects and and so if you
find purpose or meaning Chloe and in
these objects good for you hold on to
them but maybe temporarily deprive
yourself be willing to let go for a
period of time also remember this
they're just objects they're all
replaceable yeah and especially if you
just had to pack them up you could
always unpack them put them back that's
right yeah well I'd love to send you a
Chloe I love this video a copy of our
book everything that remains it's the
story of our suit-and-tie corporate guys
too minimalist there's that whole
chapter in there of me spending my time
at IKEA while the world is crumbling
around me I think the line from from
there is even while Rome was burning
there somehow time for shopping at IKEA
and and that was the particular metaphor
that I wanted to to show off there like
literally if you imagine the sum while
Rome is burning there's a soldier who
runs off to go shopping at IKEA and
that's kind of that's kind of how I felt
in retrospect certainly not in the time
but I did feel just as stressed out as
these these couples fighting in Ikea
except I was I was only fighting with
myself Julia in Los Angeles has a
question for us
how can i minimalize my physical
possessions when in Britain credibility
to my work you know sometimes having
fancy clothes cars can influence people
on believing that sure so on what to do
in other words you sort of need that
image this turned out to be a contradict
to me because spending money on this
material don't add value to my personal
life however in the industry that I work
they do make a difference
before we in the Julia's question can we
talk about the Grammys for a second no
Khalid yes lid Khalid it's clean yeah
yeah he was nominated for Best new or
new artists and didn't get it really
yeah some girl whose album came out in
2015 it's 2018 I don't know and also
sizzle was was nominated she didn't get
it jay-z's album 444 did not get Best
Album or Best Rap Album what is going on
and they had Elton John performing at
the Grammys the problem is that you care
about the Grammys judge I don't I care
about music that's fair but and Grammys
don't really represent the best of all
music though YouTube's performing you to
you to hang sting was there
shaggy was there you know shaggy it
wasn't me yeah what is going on Bruno
Mars won best album which is I mean he's
the most talented man on earth I totally
get it but it wasn't the best album of
the year yeah I don't even think I
listened to that album
I'll have to go check it out now that
a-one yeah I mean it's yeah it's sort of
like a throwback to 1990 to sort of
Teddy Riley neo-soul R&B and he's like
the Michael Jackson of our time I
totally good I think he's one of the
most talent the most talented human
beings on earth was Bruno Mars on
American Idol no okay you're thinking of
Ruben Studdard all right Julia
so the thing that I wrote down here Ryan
this is something pithy for you Sean to
put in the show notes as a minimal
maximum even though we're not at the
lightning round yet if someone likes you
for who you're trying to be rather than
who you are then it's not you they like
mm-hmm and so she talked about the the
and you could probably NAT up a little
bit it's just gonna be like a very
choppy
yeah if someone likes you fer you trying
to be then it is not you they like how
about that and and she talked about like
possessions Lyn credibility and here's
here's the first thing I'll say is
personally I actually believe that's
somewhat true in our culture yes it is
true that that our not necessarily our
choices they influence other people and
and we do want to put our best foot
forward of course what Ryan when you and
I show up at a live event
I got a nice crisp clean black t-shirt
on that's right and you're not you don't
look like you're not slovenly no you
change your underwear every day I
believe yeah as you know that's the
rumor I saw it on reddit never read
ready yet go ahead I like right at me it
was like six years ago I read it I
haven't been back I'm sure we have a
reddit thread or whatever but but me I
had people threaten this the first time
ever had someone threatened me with
physical violence online it was on all
they said is they wanted to kick you in
the nuts Josh metaphor kit nevermind so
so no continue with Julia she said that
possessions Lynn
lend her some credibility and here's
what I'll say is that can be true but I
think we also mistake expensive things
for nice things or nice things for
expensive things there are are pieces of
crap that are crazy expensive
right there are relatively inexpensive
things that are really well made I mean
the first thing that came to mind when
she was talking about her question the
the cars and the clothes influence other
people she said I remember the first
time we did an event with Joshua Becker
I think this was 2014 12 oh the south by
no we did a Phoenix thing with him we
did an event with him in Phoenix at a
bookstore there may have been 2014 was
it I mean wasn't on our 2014 tour I
don't remember what you what your
because I remember the specific instance
we went to go have lunch with him and he
gave us a ride somewhere and I got in
his car and it was like a used Honda
Accord and I remember being so impressed
could but it wasn't because of the Honda
Accord right here like nice Accord dude
although did you know at one time that
was the most stolen car yeah yeah it was
it did you see the movie New Jersey
drive yeah they used to always steal
Accords in that in that in that facility
anyway so you're anyways but not because
it was in court yeah because it was
pristine I got in there and you know me
I am OCD to the gills yeah but I got in
there I'm like huh need to clean my car
off I love it every time you borrow my
car it's all nice and hot because
everything drives me insane but I got in
the to Joshua Becker's car and I felt
like the sense of calm like it was it
wasn't a Lexus it wasn't a Range Rover I
know what you're talking about
yeah yeah so so I think that lends
itself more credibility than the logo
and by the way if the people that you're
hanging around if the people you're
hanging around are more impressed by
logos than by the person then you need
to fire their [ __ ] asses that they
are I mean you need to fire them as
friends or as co-workers find a
different job find a different career if
if those things aren't important to you
here's the thing if those things are
important to you if the logos and the
fashion and the $400 Kanye West's
sweatpants are are are important to you
then go do your thing I'm not judging
you for that
but if clearly you're struggling with
trying you're trying to be someone else
to impress the people you don't care
about that much
that's consumerism and that's the
problem we are spending money we don't
have on credit cards to buy things we
don't want or need to impress people we
don't like that is a huge problem in our
society and you can be the change agent
there so Julia it is up to you yes it's
gonna be difficult to distance yourself
but but but it is did you say change
agent yeah yeah okay well I think I
think here you know you're absolutely
right there and I'm sorry - do you
really know I think it's appropriate and
and here here's the thing Julia I feel
that that you are the person who has to
make this change you're not gonna get
the other people to change hey can you
stop being influenced by cars and
clothes no yes do you want to put your
best foot forward absolutely can you put
your best foot forward and some pretty
simple clothes that are inexpensive yes
I'm wearing a shirt from eBay right now
and I you know I'm wearing pretty basic
clothes I don't have Alexis anymore I
used to I step to Lexus's and Lex I is
the plural I think so yeah yeah look it
up and and it's because I've realized
that I can do just fine with the Toyota
right
there's this old rapper not like he's
probably old now there's a rapper from
the mid 90s named EC illa he's from
Chicago and he said a Camry will get you
girls just like a Lex can plus you'll
save 30 grand let's take the 30 grand
and spit it on your kids education and
like there was this that to me like I
wasn't ready to accept that yet because
I was what in 1994 I was 13 years old
but I look back and I'm like why didn't
I listen to that right because a camera
is gonna get you to where you want to go
just as well as Alexis's but you're
gonna save a lot of money in the process
you can do something better with yeah
not having a car payment man like that
is that is the best feeling in the world
I struggle with that because like that I
saw the camera in the 2004 I'm sorry
Carola memory um I'll replace it in that
like within this year next year but I
mean you're going to have to eventually
but it's but I'm but like not having a
car payment it is it is such a good
feeling but it's probably hard letting
go that dope Kenwood stereo you with
them tweeters so Ryan's Ryan's stereo
when I was the last last year 2017 yes I
feel the longest time Ryan I just like
rode around in silence yeah we probably
a Bluetooth speaker we have a prize with
you so it couldn't have been too silent
am i right no you're not right so we
tried to bring a bluesy speaker and that
worked okay but yeah we like what she
has a friend who's who works at like uh
you know some kind of sound I figure
what it's called Aspen's sounds waves at
the date exactly he hooked me oh [ __ ] me
open them tweeters so for those of you
are documentary and you saw me putting
the cassette tape into the deck that
deck is no longer there right no it's
not it's what's that I notice yeah so
how'd you let it go I didn't have to not
now are people unhappy with your car
Ryan oh yeah man when I when I when I
turn up them tweeters I notice there are
they unimpressed like the we know you
went where places where people judge you
oh yeah um well it's funny uh yeah I was
gonna tell you
continuing the you know what you were
talking about hanging out with people
who judge you for the brand of whatever
it is that you have I had a so when I
got rid of my my car payment and I got
the tour bus yeah um I was still on this
board I was like the the chairman of
this organization I'm just trying to
keep the loose because like I don't want
to call anyone out yeah um long story
short someone in this it that was on the
board we were walking out because there
was a bureau of sorts and as we were
walking out someone in in this in this
committee they saw me getting into my
car and they were like that's your new
car and I'm like yep and they're like I
don't like it and I was just like okay
I'm sorry you don't like it but I don't
have a car payment and I like not having
a car payment and and I thought that
person is probably not in your life
anymore that's that's not true
okay um at that at that point I
literally was thinking to myself I'm
like wow it's really really gave me a
hard time about my car and I was like
you know what like if that's if I end up
having any tension or what I can walk
away from this position it's not that
big of a deal right or if that person
walks out of my life that's okay too
like I'm not gonna sit here and I'm not
gonna let their judgment you know I'm
not gonna let that affect me at all well
because but long story short that person
actually didn't know they were one of
the people who at first they weren't
they weren't like that's the only
unsupportive thing that they ever said
when when we started that whole
transition yeah so they weren't nearly
as egregious which I would say that
wasn't even egregious well it was a
certain extent because that you
considered that person a friend yeah I
assume you know I think I know the
person you're talking absurd it was
someone on the periphery and not that
person but what you realized in that
scenario is judgment is a mirror of the
person's own insecurities right yeah the
thing that we always say judgment is
about a mirror of the securities of the
person who's doing the judging and and
so so what you really saw there is oh
that person is insecure about his or her
own debt his or her own need to fill
fulfill their identity by having the the
fancy car the big house the yeah the the
trophies of success right and that's
great for them and they sure if that's
what they really want but clearly what
they were saying is oh this isn't what I
really want because if they wanted that
for them it wouldn't matter to them
whether or not you're driving a Toyota
Corolla right they play oh that's cool
like whatever and and so you know like
with with my friends like I'm not I
would never say why do you have that
expensive what about that brand of car
yeah whether it's yeah exactly
why do you have a Maserati er so I only
have any friends with a Maserati but I
did see one in
my parking garage now there does sound
like four on the way here oh yeah it's
all the way borghini today and this guy
you can actually hear they sell they
sound really sort of unique when they're
driving passionately they have a they
have their own sound design yes
and and it's if that's what someone once
and they truly get value from it great I
wouldn't do it even if I could afford a
Lamborghini which I cannot but but if I
could I would rather put that money
somewhere else personally yeah that
doesn't mean that I'm telling someone
else that that's what they should do
dude I want a Tesla really bad yeah and
the Model X is freaking awesome
like I really love it dude that's so yes
a crossover SUV looking yeah I do like
it's really insane but the thing is it's
around say you love it
it's around six majors Brian love people
and use that I love the design of it
yeah I really appreciate the design you
know there we go okay yeah in fact I was
going back and listening to these OLAP
asad so we did last year yeah and I had
noticed how much I would say I love
something like even though I'm like at
the end of every episode I say love
people use things and I'm talking about
how I love this brand of freaking
t-shirt or something
everything we do is steep some undernea
but but what was it talking about oh
yeah model X so if somehow X X I don't
know do like I've got I've got money
invested in Tesla okay so let's say that
I made $100,000 profit off of my Tesla
investment uh-huh like you know some
kind of mere windfall yeah miracle
happen
all of a sudden but I still wouldn't I
still could not justify buying a Model X
paying cash for a mom cause it's like
yeah it's like I just what to build that
school in Laos I believe it was it ended
up being like 30-something thousand it
was just over 30 so it's like if I go
with the model 3 which is like an
expensive car but you know the money I
would save I could build two schools
like for me like I just can't I don't
know man I'd have to be like it would
have to be a really exceptional
situation where I literally had so much
money I didn't know what to do with but
but that's just but to just to be clear
I'm not judging anyone who goes out and
spends six figures on a car
uh the reason why I'm even talking about
me is because I'm trying to help Julia
show where I come from yeah and Josh is
trying to show her where where his ideas
come from but that doesn't make our
ideas and our perspectives 100% right
the one thing I do want to say though
about Julia's uniforms is they are just
that they're uniforms so she she gets to
decide it sounds like what brand her
uniform is but she gets to choose a
uniform that she feels beautiful and
yeah and that's what I would encourage
Julia to do you know one of the most
stylish people who's ever been in my
life was my mother
do you remember I mean my mom had so
many like crazy big hat see the hats man
it was always dressed to the nine even
even though she had a lot of demons and
problems like it was one thing she did
really well I don't know that she ever
bought anything brand-new she was always
going to the thrift shop goodwill the
second-hand consignment stores and she
found stuff that worked out I mean and
part of it was just being confident in
and what she was wearing right and she
looked better she was better dressed
than any anyone that I know who's gonna
you know sort of walk the red carpet and
part of that has to do with because she
felt good and what she was wearing and I
think and that's what's important yeah
and that's what I've noticed with you
Ryan and you and I have radically
simplified our wardrobe over the last
seven years since we started the
minimalists comm but but we you know I
saw a picture they have you and I out on
our first tour both wearing these weird
plaid shirts and the white shirts that's
that's the best uniform yeah I love how
we started with white and now it's
mostly black yeah there's there's some
kind of metaphor there yeah there is I
don't know we'll work on it and we'll
work on John get to work on that edit
that metaphor for us is speaking of Sean
like I I mean I love Sean no matter what
he wears right when we can do our events
I'm like Sean you got a were some black
jeans you can't work
can't wear those cargo shorts to our
event Jude Sean can't oh but he's a dad
although now so I talked about Jack
Harlow last week and his album is album
of the year so far for me gazebo and the
the song on there I'm one of the singles
it's called wasted youth and he starts
off he says I rocked the tan cargo with
the velcro slits I rocked the tan cargo
with the velcro seams so I can't feel
the vibration with my cell phone rings
I'm like the 90s are totally back I say
that picture of him yesterday and it's
like the 90s are all the way back so
maybe sean has just been ahead of the
curve this whole time I'm sure would
surprise me no in a few weeks those
jorts will be back in style Sean they're
not no they're cargo shorts oh that is
big different oh yeah
and those are totally back in style
right and they all right so I just I
just gave you the lyrics so my first
visit ever to Portland Oregon was with
you like I'm like WTF yeah this is like
with Chris Gilliam oh he's been on our
part yes that was 2011 it was 2011 was
about it was about like seven months
after we started the website yeah so
we're out there and I'm wearing that
plaid shirt yeah in the cargo shorts and
I'm like I'm so excited to be in
Portland like I had never been there and
like I am so just taken back by like the
friendliness of people in Portland the
bike the bike friendliness their bike
lanes everywhere like you can tell like
they let City really goes out of their
way to make sure that bikers have have a
good experience there and yeah all these
warned I'm feeling so good a certain
synergy to that yeah yeah let's see how
many corporate cliche words we can use
in this podcast so so you and I were
walking to get food and I've got this
I'm elated dude I feel so good I feel
working in the corporate world it feels
so good and I had like the Aviators
you at you when you had short hair
especially you were definitely
undercover cop it's not that you look
like a narc I workout I'm sure you were
undercover so so as Josh Nagin here's
some more someone yell at the window hey
dork
nice car no shorts and like any good
feeling I had just to be clear you have
flip-flops on yes well I remember I
remember later it was either that day or
the next day some guy came up to me he's
like excuse me officer and then and then
I was like oh Portland this is filled
with a bunch of judgmental of
pretentious folks okay so I think I
don't I don't think that oh no here's
here's the lesson I think is be aware of
your surroundings and I when I was in
the corporate world I used to wear a
suit every day even though it wasn't
required it was sort of recommended to
wear a tie and you know a shirt sleeves
but it was not it was not recommended to
get to work sooner but I did because I
did want to put my best foot forward and
even now being aware of your
surroundings so important you wouldn't
go back to Portland like that now you
wouldn't dress like that now period not
that there's anything inherently wrong
with dressing like that but you've
realized that that is not the best
version of yourself it's not the thing
that you look best in it's not the thing
that you feel best and you are still
finding yourself aesthetically or
stylistically right and and so I think
what the the the lesson here is find
yourself stylistically and price doesn't
doesn't necessarily equal quality and
quality certainly doesn't equal price
and so keep that in mind you can you can
what are the kids say ballin on a budget
you you you can you could definitely be
you know fresh dressed and and and and
and look clean just like Joshua Becker
is Honda Accord without without spending
the the Maserati or Tesla money yeah
just keep it lit for him
all right hey Julia Julia we know where
derail Orion's laughing at himself so
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
essential either the all of our books
are on audiobook or print or ebook so
essential has an entire chapter in there
about success and and I think ultimately
what we're telling Julia here is maybe
redefine what success looks like for you
what what is influential for you who are
the people you're actually trying to
influence because I want to be
influential but hopefully for me that
doesn't mean showing off a a logo or a
particular brand in order to influence
those dude if I showed up for brain
surgery and the doctor is dressed like
little inserts will pump little people
Luzi vert yeah I feel like I'd be like
whoa rest rest in peace little peep yet
but you understand what I'm saying
though right like yeah I'm not
it and I wish I could pull off little
peeps look I really do I would not be
able to pull that off no no the pink
hair when that wouldn't it would not it
would not fit you right exactly yeah so
we'll send you a copy of essential it's
12 different chapters on intentional
living one of those chapters is about
success
all right y'all we'd love to hear what
you all have to say so I've got to find
my notes here oh yeah here's here this
we'd love to hear what you have to say
so if you have a comment or a tip about
decorations or decorating or aesthetics
including advice for any of our callers
today's my favorite part of the show
this was at the end of the show we air
our favorite comments and tips from our
listeners you can leave this a voicemail
four oh six two one nine seven eight
three nine by the way if you sent us a
comment or tip you have a much better
chance of making it onto the show we get
fewer comments and tips from our
listeners and I like repurposing them I
in fact I like trying out some of your
tips in my own life so send those in
four oh six two one nine seven eight
three nine you can also email a voice
memo right from your phone to podcast at
the minimalists com so we've air our
favorite comments and tips at the end of
the show and on a future episode Ryan
what time is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we're on
social media we're on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram and we're back on
those platforms we're at the minimalists
on on all three platforms there we're
also on Pinterest and and YouTube
youtube.com slash the minimalists
they're our lightning rounds for Ryan
and I each do our best answer answer
each question that you have with just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pit the answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our pithy quotes in
one place minimal Maxim's calm our first
lightning round question is from Mehdi
which I believe is short for Marissa
I've never seen the word the name met
eme TT well sure from metropolis
people's wait is that an actual name no
technically it could be maybe mehdi is a
name yeti matricies what is that short
for I don't think it's short for
anything
what is Rian short for all right Mehdi
writes in my eight-year-old son collects
wooden sticks we have a rule that those
sticks do not go inside but they pile up
outside the front door and in my car any
suggestions how to address this yes l wa
has been doing this recently in fact I'm
going to share a photo on my Instagram
at Joshua fields Milburn of her stick
collection outside the front door
she used it's like right in the snow or
right in the dirt or whatever and and so
we have this little stool with her stick
collection on that stool and I'll tell
you what it actually kind of looks like
art it's a beautiful stool right outside
and I so I'll share it and there is a
way so we've been talked about
decorations in art when I BEC sent me
the picture of it I'm like that is a
good photo this actually looks like
someone put together a little stick art
and so my pithy answer for you immedi is
is here as parents we teach our children
to pick their battles but we too must
pick our battles carefully and so here's
the thing to me this isn't a battle
worth fighting
telling her that she shouldn't have
sticks I used to play with sticks as a
little kid right you play the rocks and
sticks or whatever you find I think
that's okay I think yes we have to we
have to pick our battles and here's the
thing
Medhi Ryan she said that she let the
sticks pile outside the front door
and and in her car l ain't bringing a
stick in my cars no way that's that's a
great point yeah and so you can say no
it maybe that's the other thing that's
another Pythian wait don't wait wait I
don't know wait
you're gonna ruin my pytheas okay so
that's a perfect segue into my pit the
answer why the parents job is not to
order their children around but rather
set boundaries now I totally ripped this
off from Joshua Becker's book okay
clutter free with kids but but what I'll
say is like yes you're right man if I
had a kid there's no way they're
bringing sticks into my car right and as
a parent you get to set that boundary
and yeah like I said you don't want to
order your parents around I remember
growing up when my parents ordered me
around it told me I could or couldn't do
something that was by far the worst way
to get me to to get me to go along with
them I mean of course I'd go along with
them whether I wanted to or not as a
child but but when they would actually
ask my input and let me feel like I was
making a little bit of a decision it was
so much easier for me to go along with
what they wanted to do so right yeah I
do like totally there
Meddy yes like you don't want to sit
there and sell your child no you can't
pick up sticks but you definitely want
to set boundaries that better
appropriate you say you don't want to
sit there and sell your child no said
you say sell your child that is not what
I said many my pithy answer is sell your
child I said you don't want to tell your
child oh oh well that's yeah that's
better
so I add a second pithy answer for you
here is no matter what you can always
say no but I agree with with Ryan it
it's better to say yes what are you
saying yes to hear so say yes to the
stick collection keep it outside the
door keep it within a boundary as Ryan
said and for us like Ella can keep that
little stick collection on her stool but
it doesn't grow beyond that stool and
it's the same thing we do with our
fridge she has one piece of artwork on
the fridge in order to replace that she
has to take if she wants to put
something else
there she has to take that down that is
a boundary that we've set we got another
question Ryan is it is it hung up there
with the Yeti magnet yes this sasquatch
Magda speaking which I still am in a
sasquatch coffee it's called coffee for
sasquatch it's it's on the corner of La
Brea and Melrose it is like right there
yeah it's about a mile away from here
and it is my favorite coffee shop in LA
right now
all right a few other great ones but
that's have you been to go get them
tiger yet no it's over in lunch
Larchmont it's that's a great coffee
shop - you got to try it out I'll drag
you over there but coffee for sasquatch
aesthetically and the coffee it's just
all-around it's beautiful
Rachel writes in being an art fan and a
minimalist how do you curate your art
collection my pet the answer is art
extends beyond the framed objects on our
walls so that's a perfect bookend here
the we were talking about this earlier
like anything can be art and it's not
just the visual side of things well it's
the physical so the the physical objects
it can be the way that something sounds
that's one thing we're trying to
accomplish with the studio space is make
sure that it sounds beautiful I think
we're 90% of the way there we may end up
getting a rug here we actually feel one
more sound panel here or moving some of
those over to to close the gap a little
bit so it looks great aesthetically
that's a type of artwork symmetry is a
type of artwork so so art extends beyond
the framed objects on our walls here's
the other thing I'll say though not
everything is art the guy putting his
glasses down in the museum that's a type
of performance art in a way because he's
doing it but just the glasses themselves
aren't necessarily all right I don't
know man are just kind of perspective I
will do yeah III do I definitely agree
with that but you know what isn't our
someone putting a crucifix in a jar of
urine that that is that is provocation
that and yeah it certainly creates a
visceral feeling right right but but
that's not our some of the stuff I see
at LACMA is is interesting but it's you
personally would not consider it or yeah
I think I'd probably the majority of
people I understand I think I think
there there are some things you can say
objectively aren't art yeah I guess I
would yeah I personally don't feel
confident enough to look at anything and
say it is reason art because I'm just
not skilled in art at all okay I have no
I have no like formal education I could
not tell you the different art periods
I'm sure and and yeah I'm not as
well-versed on that as I'd like to be it
but here's here's the thing I'll say
there are things there the opposite is
also true so occasionally Bex and I will
rent this cabin in the middle of Montana
it's like on top of this mountain you
don't see anything else around there's
deer out there you hear wolves howling
and night we've seen elk just herds of
them that's not art but it's truly
beautiful right now you could paint that
and it would be the painting would be
art yeah but but it's it's truly beauty
winner and it's like looking at art it's
it's like that
but it isn't actually art it's just
nature right I'm with you and so there
are some things that are objectively not
art and and at the only reason I say
that it with with my pithy answer here
is yes a lot most of the things that we
bring into our home I treat it like art
I want a couch that looks like art if
I'm gonna have a couch I want a coffee
table that is aesthetically pleasing I
would call that a type of art it may not
be the traditional type of art but there
are some things that just aren't art
dude there is this the I don't know what
you would call it it's a glass container
there's an eight there's a there's a
jargon for this but it's what I use to
make my coffee and so I put the the the
pour over filter on top of this UMX it's
not a Chemex it's a metal or it's oh I'm
sorry it's oh it's a glass it's just a
glass jaw raff yeah I don't know what
you would call anyway Jarro makes it huh
which this might be my value-added maybe
but it's it is an amazing it's just an
amazing piece of art it's like probably
one of my favorite pieces of art and I
use it every single morning it's really
funny it's like and I've broken it
before and got really a glass server I'm
looking at right now and Hario v60 glass
sir
and it's like I've broken it before him
like really bummed out I'm like man I
really love using that thing yeah um
anyway see I like that when you just
said love using it I'd love the
experience of that as opposed to loving
the thing right yeah and because for you
it's not about the particular item like
I have this glass here in front of me
that holding up so I love this thing and
if it breaks my my heart is broken you
love the experience of using a sofa
breaks you're like I can't have that
experience right yeah so it's much more
about the experience that that creates
and it also creates an aesthetic beauty
I agree with you that that that the
glass server is it's it is to me that's
a piece of art gorgeous yeah all right
so my pet the answer for Rachel is this
I buy art if three things happen Mariah
whoa whoa hold on so I'm gonna list them
out here one Mariah and I love it too
Mariah and I have room for it three we
don't have to go into debt to buy it so
Mariah and I right now we've definitely
got room for a couple more art pieces we
don't go out seeking it we we had a one
gifted to us for Christmas a piece of
art which is beautiful and I'm happy to
to put it up if we're out and about we
see another piece of art like we totally
have the room for it if we can afford it
we'd get it yeah but I don't feel
incomplete without without that piece of
my wall without art on it if that makes
sense yeah I think when you say afford
it also is it you're like is this the
best use of this money so if this sure
if this object cost $100 it is for me is
this the best use of that hundred
dollars from yeah well I think the
problem too is people will it's they
will go into debt they'll put something
on their credit card right for something
that they really really love and you
know I would I would challenge people
out there who were doing that if you are
in debt even if you really love
something you can't afford it you can't
afford it you shouldn't buy it and
that's that's how I try to how I try to
live my life fine if I were to pin your
aunt's erection I pin if I were to amend
it you said number one Ryan or Mariah
and I love it maybe what I would say is
find joy in it right because it's going
back to the Lovings if you wait yeah I'm
not gonna get caught up in the semantics
man I mean I understand what you're
saying about semantics it's for me it's
it there there's
true meaning behind that word and we've
we've overused it to say I love tacos
and I say it all the time Stella Shan
this gesture is a great taco place right
down the stream I love those tacos I'm
like why the hell did I just say that
but but the thing is is that there is a
the the denotation which is what you're
talking about right now right the
meaning of love but centuries of using
this word has a there are so many
different connotations with the word
love agreed and I've tried I'm trying to
take it back this is always going old
school the same one's gonna bring out
that agape love know what yeah it's like
the same way that that the end you would
have you know 15 or 20 words for
different types of snow right we it
feels like we need multiple words for
love and that's why I say joy it is it I
don't wanna make up words or I don't
want to turn words like spark into a
verb like certain people do shots fired
and although I know I see Starbucks
using that as well like gifts that spark
joy no spark is not a verb it is a noun
and yes the language can change over
time and it has what the word love and I
want to take that back the same way that
sam harris is trying to take back the
word spirituality i wouldn't use the
word spirituality personally i would use
the word numinous but but he he's you
know trying to say well it me
it can mean something else and for me
love I would rather love people and use
things alright and and one way that you
use things is to get joy from them I
think they augment or magnify or amplify
our experience of life and I think
that's altima we were talking about is
is is this object this art that you
purchase it is going to it is going to
augment your experience of living in
your home yeah I am happy to support you
in taking back the word love Josh give
it to me in Harding you edit that pithy
answer however you want man all right
shall we see oh yeah it's time for added
value portion of the show this where we
each talk about something that has added
value to
Our Lives recently Ryan what do you got
have you heard of pornhub you mean pH
Beck's is out of town this week now I
was a book called sapiens I'm sure
you've heard of it everyone has heard of
it that's that's so funny because this
loosely ties in with what I'm
recommending but keep going ok cool yeah
yeah so you've all her re wrote wrote
two books the first one of the two that
I've read is called sapiens here's the
thing I read it and on the Kindle
version some time last year but I went
back and and just listen to the whole
audiobook it's like 15 hours I listen to
it in January of this year the audiobook
is way better for whatever reason it had
me it had me pausing and like taking
notes about consumerism and and going
back to the different types of humans
because obviously Homo sapiens aren't
the only humans we had Neanderthals
which I am more Neanderthal than 92% of
the population I believe but also Homo
erectus and there were several other
human species and sapiens are the ones
who ended up living living beyond all of
their other ancestors and so it talks
about in fact I think the subtitle of it
is a brief history of humankind and it
is a phenomenal book but especially the
audio books Sean I think put a link to
the audio book in the show notes I
encourage people to check it out it's
it's like I feel like all the books I
read in history class and I liked
history class for the most part like I
just needed to read this book if I
really wanted to get interested in
history yeah it is so good and then his
his new one is called homo Deus it's
like a brief it's a brief history of
tomorrow
it's like yeah the human human future
sort so to speak that's pretty cool ya
know so this book sapiens mariah's dad
recommended it to me mmm-hmm her mom is
reading it right now um but yeah he was
just going on and on about it how you
were I haven't read or listened to it
yet I need to check it out it's so good
the reason why it's tied in is because
the person who gave us a painting it was
Mariah's dad oh so John Schneeberger
calm other people can go and check out
his paintings so I would totally
recommend his website he he does pastel
drawings so what he does is he goes
around Montana and he takes different
pictures and then he does a pastel so he
hooked that he'll photograph you know
saw the Bitterroot Mountains and then
he'll go to his his studio and then do a
pastel drawing yeah and he is he's so
freaking talented so yeah it's uh and
he's not like you know he's not like
this crazy um it's gonna be $1,500 for
one of my drawings like it's it's
beautiful Montana mountain scenery and
it's it's it's really affordable artwork
and it's it's awesome Sean I think you
put a link to that and the show notes
good luck spell and Schneeberger I'll
send you the link I always struggle with
with Schneeberger when I'm booking plane
tickets for Mariah and her her last name
is like hyphenated as well she has both
of her parents know I always joke like
when Mariah and I have kids we should
hyphenate it again I totally be
hilarious who's gonna be the generation
of a family that that ruins the the
hyphenation of the names I think if you
have a son you should name him Pizza
Pizza Pizza Nicodemus no B Pizza Pizza
Coombes knee burger Nicodemus it's the
best author name I I will certainly um
I'll put that into the consideration the
file the consideration file hey Shawn
also put the I'll find a link for the
Haro the glass thing are you are you
yeah where does it go a glass serving
container it's called glass server okay
cool all right it's time for right here
right now so we talked about what is
going on in the lives of the minimalists
we are headed to Australia
holy moly with seven cities we're headed
to Perth that one is almost sold out
Adelaide I think there's fewer than 50
tickets and a delay so that one's almost
sold out Brisbane fewer than 50 tickets
left in Brisbane Sydney there's fewer
than 200 tickets left in Sydney that's a
huge venue it's almost 2,000 people
there so Sydney get your tickets while
you can
Melbourne we
that one sold out but we added a second
show and that one's about halfway sold
out in Melbourne so if you're in
Melbourne you want tickets to the second
show you can still get that and then
Oakland we're gonna be in New Zealand as
well so aqil in New Zealand we have one
stop in New Zealand come out and see us
in March all the details are at the
minimalists comm slash tour also if you
want the show notes we keep talking
about throughout these episodes we email
them to all of our readers and listeners
you must go over to our website enter
your email address right there at the
top and we'll send you any any of the
show notes to any new episode that we
send out also any new essays that we
write I've been working two months on
this advertisments essay I've never
spent this much time writing one essay
doing a bunch of research it's really
long I'm just trying to pair it I'm
trying to get it below 10,000 words
right now hopefully it'll be below 5,000
words I'm cutting a whole lot of stuff
out of it but I sort of had to build the
mountain in order to to carve away at it
build the the rock to carve away at it
but if you want the show notes just
enter your email address there we'll
never ever send you spam because that's
gross we won't ever send you stuff you
don't want just new essays and and new
podcast show notes for every episode we
put out there we have a video podcast
version of this podcast coming really
soon over at youtube.com slash the
minimalist so you can subscribe to our
YouTube channel over there if you're
interested in the video version we're
gonna do that as soon as we get enough
patreon supporters to to get the video
equipment up and running here in Los
Angeles and if you do want to support us
on patreon you settling over to the
minimalists com click donate at the top
each week Ryan and I do a patreon bonus
episode we call it the minimalist
private podcast now I know what you're
saying man Josh and Ryan I don't want to
have to log on to the Internet's listen
to a separate podcast episode I want to
listen to it right here on my phone and
I don't have to download all these other
things you don't have to do any of that
our bonus podcast episode every week
shows up right there in your whatever
podcast app you're listening to right
now so you're on Apple podcasts or
overcast or feedly or Google Play or
whatever all you need is our private
podcast link in order to get that you
become a patreon supporter each week we
do an overtime episode
all I think about changing the name on
that instead of overtime what what if we
call it PostScript or do you like
overtime better I
I am ambivalent what do you think
podcast on PostScript can I get a hand
or or overtime he's given me the 50 I
like the effect like I've had to choose
that over time but you're you're the
you're the you're the guy with the good
words though Millburn yeah bill maher
doesn't overtime thing I was just trying
to make see if there we could do
something original I just want to know
do you actually when you go to the
internet do you log onto it every single
time because if you do Josh I've got
news for you I mean I have to dial up
that's in an Internet where you don't
have to log on I mean so here's the
thing like there are other there other
podcasts out there I'm like on slate
were you like if you want if you want
their Ganesha Ganesha nation he just
sneezed and Ella says Ganesha nation
instead of gesundheit and so we've just
adopted that just keep it going yeah and
so yeah we're going to do a PostScript
episode we're gonna answer a question
here we had a a postscript question
overtime question we'll figure out what
the what to call it here Janelle asked
what do you do with decorative items you
want to get rid of but no one else once
as a kid my family traveled a lot and I
collected hundreds of junk items from
all over the places that we visited I
don't want these items anymore
but neither would anyone else so what
we'll have an answer for that
during our overtime slash PostScript
episode we'll figure out what to call
that over on patreon also last week we
just put out on patreon our live
philadelphia event so if you want to
hear our event that we did in
philadelphia live in front of a sold-out
crowd there and then we also just put up
the Detroit and it's hamper live
episodes only for our patreon supporters
you can go back and listen to dozens of
private podcast episodes so if you've
gotten your your fix of the minimalists
and you want some shorter bite-sized
episodes we've got a bunch of those and
we also do a monthly live stream for our
patreon supporters we call it ask the
minimalists anything where you can ask
Gus anything it's used just people
asking Ryan about his boxers or briefs
all right so what else do we have going
on here what I do have for you boys no
comments and tips from our listeners hi
this is Cecilia from Riva Ohio and the
new leader for the Cleveland minimalist
meetup group I would like to pass along
a different way to think about the love
language of receiving gifts to be clear
receiving gifts is not one of my love
languages however acts of service and
quality time are I enjoy showing the
people I love my appreciation for them
as humans by randomly gifting them with
an experience or a consumable for
instance I will bring my staff of
discard for a restaurant or a gas card
out of the blue and thank them for their
loyal service to me another example I
frequently randomly gift my daughter I'm
using the upcoming Chinese New Year as
an inspiration for gifting her to show
her that I love and appreciate her in
Chinese tradition gifts of sweet fruits
and money and even denominations for
good luck are given so I homemade some
Chinese almond cookies that she loves
bought some oranges and will get give
her a $2.00 bill so her next cup of
coffee will be on me my daughter Aston
tree analyzed my gifting practices and
concluded that my gifting of consumables
and experiences to people is really
manifesting outwardly a combination of
my two love languages acts of service
and quality times she thinks that look
at gifting as a service to that receiver
and it is also in a way that I can spend
quality time with that person hi this is
Kara from Seattle and I just going in
reference to Mali in epicene and 118
when she was talking about her trophies
one cool thing that I did was I took all
the little name plates off and I kept
them all like in a scrapbook you could
do that or you could even put them in
the shadow box with your medals or just
set them up and take a really cool
picture and then keep that otherwise
check the trophies and you know just
enjoy the memories but letting go hi
this is Molly from Salt Lake City
I'm calling the tip regarding managing
the collecting impulse or strategy I
have used is to make friends with people
who share the same
hobby or collection and do regular
exchanges with them so you get the
thrill of having a new item but then
when the turtle wears off you just
return it to the other owner and you can
get another new item when you get it
back all right Joe that's it for this
episode if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for 0 6 2 1 9
7 8 3 9 you can also email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists comm and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
Ryan thanks for listening y'all we'll
see you next time
Joshua
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
[Music]
you
[Music]